he is the co-founder of the center for
humane technology who is featured in the
new netflix
documentary the social dilemma tristan
harris
hey how you doing
great to see you okay so first of all
what a great documentary not all
documentary there's some reenactments in
there and i'm going to get to that in a
minute but i wanted to ask you first
about the election you know everyone who
voted thinks
they made a free and fair choice
certainly free
my free will but what you're getting at
is that because of the manipulation that
goes on from social media where most
people get their news now
it really wasn't a free choice in every
sense of the word was it
no well i mean so the thing i think
people need to get
is that we are ten years into this mind
warp
where we have been fed a individualized
reality roger mcnamee you had on here a
few years ago talks about is the truman
shows we've got three billion truman
shows
and everyone thinks that because you
know imagine a husband and wife couple
they follow the same friends on facebook
they've got the same friends so if they
open up facebook they should see the
same feed
but that's not actually how it works
they'll actually see completely
different
realities based on what the algorithms
will say this is the thing that's likely
to keep you here
and what that did is took the shared
reality we have
put it through a paper shredder and gave
each of us a micro reality in which
we're more and more certain that we're
right and the other side is wrong
and it's totally confused us i mean
we're so confused we're 10 years into
this process now
which nobody voted on no it just
happened and we
of course are always seduced by
convenience no one wants to give up the
phone i mean you know
i can't imagine doing that correct but
one thing i love that you portray
as i was alluding to a minute ago in the
movie is you personify what an algorithm
is really i mean an algorithm is
just inside the computer but you have
three actors there
as from mad men in fact the actor from
madman right
and and they're watching this guy on
screens and they're and we see them
making decisions
about how they can manipulate him or
we're going to send him an alert
or we're going to say he got a like on
that oh we're going to tell him that
there's a woman he's interested in
within a hundred feet
or his ex-girlfriend that he has right
so maybe we'll use the ex-girlfriend
that'll get him back
and this is what's i mean without people
actually doing that that is what's going
on
right yeah that's right so i mean even
take if you try to eat
it is evil i mean that's the whole point
is we because of this competition for
attention the company started getting
really aggressive
about how what could they dangle in
front of your nervous system to get you
to come
back if you ever try to delete your
facebook account
it'll actually show you uh five friends
faces and says are you sure you want to
delete your account these five photos
these five friends
they're gonna miss you so it's like a
digital drug lord when you when you
leave
they try to figure out something to
dangle in front of you to convince you
to to come back
and it's really just you know it's it's
destroyed our mental health of our
teenagers
it's polarized our societies it's
addicted each of us
and it has really warped i think the the
psyche that
now we are in the middle of with this
election because i think
much like a psychotic patient has a mind
that is fractured against itself
we our national psyche is now fractured
against itself if you look at
even the examples that count the vote
people in the stop the count
there's a great stat recently that
republicans estimate
that a third of democrats are lgbtq
even though only six percent are and
democrats estimate
that um 38 percent of republicans make
more than 250
000 a year even though it's only two uh
two percent of republicans make that
much money
so we we really have been confused by
these individual realities
that have warped all of our perceptions
and it's especially dangerous now
because
a great deal of the country is going to
believe
that this election is stolen yeah that
joe biden is not
legitimate president and then what then
what happens
because then it's not like facebook is
going to shut
that side down or or are they
um are they going to i mean they've
taken the
companies have now taken moves that we
never saw up until a few months ago
that's right and it's due to a lot of
the public pressure that they haven't
acted enough so there's this weird
situation we're in where if you let the
frankenstein run
without any controls and so anything
goes viral if it gets the most clicks
and likes
that just rewards the most conspiracy
theories alex you know youtube for
example recommended alex jones infowars
conspiracy theories
15 billion times which is more than the
combined traffic of new york times
washington post guardian fox news
combined and when you just realize the
scale
of all of that um conspiracy theories
are especially dangerous because they're
like a trust bomb
they warp your perception of everything
that comes after it in fact the best
predictor
of whether you'll believe in a new
conspiracy theory is whether i already
got you to believe
in one and once you believe for example
the election is rigged or it's stolen
then you perceive everything through
that lens and it warps all of your
perceptions
you